TAL OPPENHEIMER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Tal Openheimer.
I'm a product manager
on the Chrome team,
and I'm here to talk to
you about the mobile web
and how you can create
amazing mobile experiences,
particularly for users in India.
So, as we know, in
India in particular,
we see users coming online
for the very first time
on their mobile devices.
This means that
they're interacting
with the experiences that
you build on a smartphone,
and they haven't necessarily
interacted with it
on any other device.
Now, when we talk about the
mobile web and mobile overall,
we know that there are
different constraints that
come in when users are
accessing your experience
on a mobile device.
Screen sizes can vary quite
greatly, with a lot of devices
being relatively small in size.
We know that RAM can
also vary, and we still
see a number of devices with
512 megabytes, RAM coming out
in the market.
And what's more,
on-device storage
can also vary to
the same extent.
There are a lot of devices
that are still coming out
with four gigabytes of on-device
storage, and so a lot of users
are relying on external SD
cards for their storage needs.
And this means that
when you're developing
for these users
on these devices,
you have some different
challenges when you're
thinking about how
to actually deliver
your experience to them.
With native apps, installs
can be a real barrier.
Users need to take an
extra step to even interact
with your experience
in the first place,
and they don't necessarily
know what they're getting.
And so you have this extra step
that you're expecting users
to take before they've even
seen what you have to offer.
What's more is even if
users take this extra step
to install your experience,
the storage constraints
on their device can make
it really problematic
for them to actually
be able to install it,
even if they're trying to.
And so you need to focus a
lot on shrinking your APK size
and making it small so
that it can actually
fit on people's devices.
And finally, we're all
developing things frequently
and improving our
experience constantly,
and you always want to make
sure your users are up-to-date.
But with all of these
various constraints,
both on a connectivity
standpoint
and with just the storage
space on your device,
it can become really
challenging to get users
on the latest experience
with the best features
that you've built, and
keeping them up-to-date
can be really hard.
But there is a
platform that all users
have on their smartphone
that actually addresses
a number of these issues.
The mobile web is set
up to actually help
with a lot of these problems.
With the mobile web, your
experience right off the bat
is accessible to everyone,
without any install barrier.
This means that they
can navigate to it
and see the experience
you have immediately.
They don't need to take
any extra steps from there.
As a result, storage
constraints that
might be introduced due to their
device and the sort of profile
of that device aren't
a problem for them
to interact with their
experience for the very
first time.
And as you actually improve
your experience on the platform,
the users are
automatically up-to-date.
The next time they navigate
to your experience,
it's right there.
They have the latest feature.
You don't need to
worry about convincing
them to install an update
or anything of that sort.
But in addition to
just the constraints
that the mobile web can
address, the mobile web
also has an incredible reach.
Looking at the average
apps use per month,
we see that on native,
a user on average
visits about 25
native apps per month,
compared to mobile, where we
see four times this amount,
with users navigating
to over 100 mobile web
experiences per month.
And this really translates to
a drastically increased reach.
Looking at the top 1,000 mobile
websites and the top 1,000
native apps, we see that
on average the mobile web
sees roughly 2 and
1/2 times the number
of unique monthly visitors.
And so by having a
mobile web experience,
you're really able to get more
users and expand that growth.
What's more, a recent
analysis by Morgan Stanley
found that not only
is there a difference
in the discoverability
and the access
that people have to mobile
web, but this is actually
growing at a faster rate.
So we're seeing two times the
growth of mobile web traffic
than we are seeing to
native mobile traffic.
And just to put
this in perspective
and give a specific
example here,
Flipboard recently launched
a mobile web experience.
And when they launched
this experience,
they saw a 75% increase in
their user base on mobile.
And this was on mobile overall,
not just on mobile web.
So by launching this
mobile web experience,
they were able to
grow their user base
across the board on mobile
because they were moving some
of these barriers to
people interacting
with their experience
in the first place.
And beyond just the
reach of mobile web,
there's a lot that the mobile
web and that we on the Chrome
team are working on to make sure
that the experience users get
across the web is one that
works really well, particularly
with some of the
constraints and challenges
that we see in India.
While we already have
a data saver feature
on Chrome for
Android, we recently
launched an improvement
to our data saver feature
that lets users save up
to 70% of their data,
and we launched
this in India first.
What this feature does is when
we identify a particularly
slow network, we
replace most images
on the page with placeholders
so that users remain in control
of where their data is going.
Users can still load
images as needed
by either long pressing
on a single image
or just selecting load
all images for that page.
And so what we've
done here is help
to remove the barrier for those
users who are particularly
sensitive to data to make
sure that they're always
able to access the experiences
that they want and need
on the mobile web.
But we also know that
sometimes users are just
completely offline, and
we want to make sure
that the mobile web works
well for them as well.
And, as a result, we're
currently doing a field trial
for a new feature that will
let users proactively offline
content on the mobile web.
This way users can
reliably know that if they
need a piece of information
on your experience
or across the web
in general, they
can get it whether
they're online or offline.
But in addition to some of
these improvements that we've
made on Chrome, we've
also been working
to improve the mobile
web platform as a whole,
to make sure that it really
works well in India and beyond.
And as part of this, we're
introducing a new concept
called progressive web apps.
And what this really does
is builds on the experience
that we have in Chrome,
but in a more general area,
to make sure that you have
all the capabilities you
need on the mobile web.
And to talk more
about that, I'm going
to hand it over to Paul
Kinlan, a developer
advocate on Chrome team.
PAUL KINLAN: Hey,
Tal, thank you.
Hi, everyone.
I won't lie.
I'm a little bit nervous.
I've got my water because
my mouth is getting dry.
And I'm told that
this is a flat table,
so I'm going to
put us over there.
But in the meantime, I'm
going to ask you a question.
Who's excited about "Star Wars?"
Good, a couple of
people, that's good.
Who wants to know how it ends?
No one, good, because I don't
know how it ends either.
So I actually do want to
ask some serious questions.
So who in the audience is
builds native applications, not
primarily but just a
part of the-- just builds
native applications Android?
[INAUDIBLE]
I know one person
builds for the web
because I've seen the tweets.
Who's JSLovers?
There's someone in the audience
who-- there we are, hello.
I see your tweets.
So who's a web developer?
That's good.
It's a good number.
So I'm here to talk about a
progressive web applications.
Actually, this is my slide.
This is me.
It doesn't really
matter that much.
But I'm here to talk about
progressive web applications.
And one of the things
I want to talk about,
and I'm going to use constantly
or try to use constantly
throughout this experience,
is this experience
created by Flipkart.
We think that this is a
progressive web application.
And what we mean by a
progressive web application
are a number of things.
One is that kind of
traditional web applications
that can work across, in theory,
any browser from UC Mini up
to the current or the
latest versions of Chrome.
But ideally, they're enhanced
through progressive enhancement
as the browser
capabilities become greater
on each of the browsers.
So we know, for instance,
that UC Mini, especially,
doesn't necessarily
always support JavaScript.
You should be able to
build a progressive web
application that ultimately
works across these browsers.
And then as the browser
capabilities get more enhanced,
you can kind of level
up the experiences
with more kind of
features and capabilities.
But that's kind of
the website the thing.
That's kind of the progressive
web part of progressive web
applications.
And the apps part
is one of the things
that we've been trying to work
on of the last couple of years
in the Chrome team
is trying to let you
as a web developer build more
engaging app-like experiences.
And there are a number
of things that we
know that these
experiences need to do
and that we know where
a number of things where
the Android and the
iPhone app ecosystem
excels over kind of what
you can deliver on the web.
And primarily, it's all about
working offline and building
kind of resilient
applications that
work especially well
in scenarios where
there's either port networks
or 2G or kind of high latency
as well.
They work offline, like we said.
But they're also
fast and smooth.
And what we mean
by fast and smooth
is like they're move
to interact with.
You click a button,
and it does the thing
that you want it to do.
But more importantly,
it loads instantly.
And normally,
native applications
work quite well in this scenario
because all the kind of content
and logical and structure
is kind of downloaded when
you do that first download.
We don't always get
that on the web.
But they're also really easy
to reengage with as well.
Like native
applications have a lot
of features which allow users
to kind of keep coming back
to your application, whether
it's something that's
on the home screen and they
can tap and it loads instantly,
or whether it's via
something like a push
notification, where
they have contextually
relevant and timely
information to the user that
is delivered to that device.
They tap it and go
into the application.
And for a long
time, we've not been
able to do that on the web.
But we've been working on these
technologies for a little while
inside Chrome, and we think
kind of the progressive web apps
kind of brand, or not
brand essentially, but name
an moniker, actually
kind of identifies
like all these
different technologies
that we brought to
the web to enable
you to build these kind of
native-like experiences.
So I briefly kind of talked
about all the different kind
of capabilities that
you kind of want
to get from an application
platform at least.
But fundamentally,
they're broken
into three different areas.
The fact that users
and developers want
their experiences
to be installable
and on to the device and
immediately accessible
to the users when they tap on
the iPhone, their performance,
as in like they're
smooth to scroll,
but they also load
instantly, and then
ultimately they're engaging.
They integrate with all the
device's native features as
and when the user needs them.
So I want to talk
about some of the work
that we've been doing on
the Chrome side of things
and also with the
browser vendors
as well, including
Mozilla and Opera,
to talk about how you can
make installable experiences.
And the first, and one of the
most popular features that
developers requested, was the
ability to add-to-home-screen.
Now, Flipkart have done
this experience as well with
add-to-home-screen, where
they can get your experience
installed onto the device.
And it's done in
a couple of ways,
and I'm going to talk about
how it's done with the manifest
file in the minutes.
But fundamentally, once
Chrome understands and knows
that your experience is a
progressive web application,
we can do the prompt that we
saw a second ago automatically,
to ask the user
whether they want
to install this
experience on the device,
whether they want
to have a closer
relationship with
that experience.
And Flipkart do a
really nice thing,
where in the top
right of the screen,
there's a little person icon.
They defer the fact that we
can tell the user that they
can install this experience
to a point in time
when they want the user
to install the experience.
So we have the heuristics
behind the scenes that
let you build these installable
experiences but don't
get in the way of
the user trying
to complete a transaction.
The next to this is
that they want you,
once you've actually got your
experience on the home screen,
normally, on the web,
when you click the link,
you get a white screen and
a URL bar across the top,
and it kind of sits there
for a good couple of seconds,
and it takes a little
while to load up.
Well, you don't want that
in an app-like experience.
So recently, we've just
introduced the splash screen.
And the idea behind
a splash screen
is you can get your
brand and your presence
inside that loading experience.
While the browser is trying to
load up, boot up, and also load
up your experience, you
can have your brand there
until the first pane happens.
And then once that happens,
you're in complete control.
And again, it's quite
simple to implement.
And the way that
you do implement
the add-to-home
screen experience,
you don't need things like
ServiceWorker, which we've also
talked a little bit
about the rest of today,
is you just need a manifest
file and a small piece of HTML.
The manifest file basically
describes how your experience
should appear on the
user's device-- what
is the name on the
home screen, what
is the icon that should be
displayed that the user needs
to click.
But you can also describe what
kind of the theme color is.
Like when the user goes
to the tab switcher, what
is the color of the application
bar across the side.
But more importantly, you
can describe and control
exactly how you want the user
to enter your experience.
So you can provide things
like the start URL, which
lets the user basically
boot up and go
to the front page, rather than
a random page in the application
that they might have bookmarked.
And you can also do
other things like control
whether it launches full
screen, which is probably
the thing that you want to do if
you're building an application,
or whether it launches
in a browser tab.
And you can also control
things like the orientation
that it starts in.
So if you're
building a game, you
can start in landscape, versus
the default of portrait.
And then you just link
to the manifest or maybe
a single page, and
then Chrome will
be able to then offer
that prompt to the users.
But once we've got our
application installed
or installed on the device,
the worst thing that can happen
is that the user
clicks the link,
and then if you don't have
an internet connection,
it just gets the
Chrome error page.
That's a really bad
experience for users,
as it's a really poor
thing for developers
because we don't want
these experiences not
to look like they're
part of the system.
So we've introduced a new
API call ServiceWorker
and it's basically
a logical extension
to some other offline
APIs that we've had.
But the most important
thing is that ServiceWorker
adds an app-like lifecycle to
your web app and your web page.
Web pages normally,
they live and die
with kind of the amount of
time that the user's on them.
They load up.
You get a couple of
events that come through
that you can respond to, such
as unload and a whole bunch
of other things.
And then when you close it,
that's the end of the session.
With ServiceWorker,
it's basically
pushed into the system so that
it can live in the background.
It's a piece of JavaScript that
can live in the background,
then respond to system events.
It can respond to
browser events,
such as every single HTTP
request coming from your page.
Or it can response
to other system level
events, such as things
like push notifications.
But the important thing here
is it lives in the background,
but only wakes up
when the operating
system tells it to wake up.
So it's in an idle state for
the majority of his time.
The first event that you do
get, or the first state it's in,
though, it's activated.
It's working.
It's doing something.
And the very first time that you
get into the activated state,
you get this thing
called an install event.
And, at that point,
you can decide
exactly how you want to kind of
start offline your experience.
You can make your--
you can basically
download all your assets, your
index page, your JavaScript,
your HTML, and your CSS.
The way to think of it, it's
like a completely scriptable
install process.
Whereas where you're in the Play
Store or the Apple App Store,
you press install, and it
downloads all the packages.
The user's never taken away
from the page in this case.
They're using their
application at their website.
But in the background,
you're controlling
what assets are needed for the
user to be able to go offline.
But at this point, things are
installed where you're not
actually working offline.
You, as a developer, have to
do some more to get there.
So the Flipkart
experience, again,
is a great example of
exactly how this works.
But the idea is that every
single time that the browser
requests a page and your
ServiceWorker is installed
in the system, every
single time they
request a page for
your domain, you'll
be able to get an
event that says,
we need to fetch this
URL from the server.
And then that point, you can
decide exactly what to do.
Like think of the ServiceWorker
at this point like a completely
scriptable client-side
proxy service
that is controlled
by a JavaScript.
So the request comes in, and you
can decide exactly what to do.
And in Flipkart's case, they've
already got all the assets
that they need.
But as you navigate
around the site,
they've already pre-cached all
the pages that you've been to.
So that when you do go offline--
and they do like a nice little
kind of grey effect.
When you do go offline,
you get the ability to say,
well, I can still go
back to those pages,
and I can still
view the content.
I might not be able to
complete the transaction,
but you're still
inside that experience.
And this is one of those
experiences where we've never
really had this on the web.
It's not been amazingly
possible to do.
And it is possible
now with ServiceWorker
and a bunch of other APIs.
But that's not
just the only thing
that you can do
with ServiceWorker
in terms of understanding
all the network
requests that go through.
You can also make your
experiences performance
as well.
And again, this is
entirely due to the fact
that your ServiceWorker is
completely in your control.
Every single request that
comes through from your page,
you get to decide what to do.
And we can make it
fast, even on 2G.
And actually, I
want to call out;
I'm on Wi-Fi when I
recorded this video.
But the Wi-Fi is a
simulated 2G network,
so this is loading like it's
on a 2G network at the moment.
And the reason why
you can actually
get this kind of performance
benefit from ServiceWorker
itself is because,
again, you have
a number of different
strategies that you can
use inside your ServiceWorker,
For instance, one strategy you
could use is offline first.
You always make sure that you
check the cache that you've
stored of all the assets
that you've gone through
and then return them.
If they're in the cache,
that's what the user sees.
If it's not in the cache,
you go out to the network.
And this is great.
If you've got a
JSON-based API, you
can just incrementally
update the page
and cache the results
as you go along.
But it's not just about
kind of ServiceWorker;
there are a number
of other things
that we've done inside
the browser recently
to help you as web developers
make more intelligent decisions
about how you actually
control the network
side and the service
side of your experience.
And traditionally, the
web, you had the client,
and then you had the server.
And the server really doesn't
know much about the client.
It doesn't know any
kind of information
about what the user's
device is, apart
from the user agent string.
And we've made a couple
of changes in Chrome
recently to give you extra
kind of context and information
in every single HTTP request,
if you are, as a developer,
opt into it.
So, for instance, you can
understand the screen density,
the DPR, or the screen width.
And then you can serve
up different images
and different assets based on
if it's a super low-density
screen, then you don't want to
send a high-density image down
the wire because people aren't
going to see all those pixels.
We're also doing some
other things as well,
which they haven't
quite landed just yet,
but they're being worked on.
And Tal mentioned before with
the demo about not loading
the images when we know
we're on an impaired network,
we also have a save data hint.
And the idea behind the save
data hint and the header
there is that you can
decide as a developer,
oh, I know that the
user has actually
opted in to use the
data compression proxy.
Therefore I'm not
going to do things
which would suck
up their bandwidth
and suck up their data.
For instance, you
might say, I'm not
going to play auto play images
when the user has a save data
hint on.
And we also a thing
called downlink max.
And when I was in Bangalore
a couple of weeks ago,
loads of developers were
asking for the ability
to understand what the
maximum performance
of the current
user's connection is.
And we have downlink max
inside Chrome right now.
But it only reports the maximum
viable connection speed.
So, for instance, it will say
I can do 52 kilobits a second,
or whatever is for 2G.
That doesn't actually say
what the network quality is
like at the moment,
but it gives you
a good indication of what type
of network the user is on.
So you, again, can
make a sane decision
about how to set up
assets to your users.
And also, we know it's
actually quite hard
to build these experiences,
especially when there's lots
of different variables at play.
So we've also got a tool
called PageSpeed Service.
It can integrate into
Engine X or Apache.
And the idea behind it
is it can automatically
do a whole bunch of
these optimizations,
so you don't have to make a
whole load of changes to your
build process and your
deployment process.
You just basically kind of put
this one line in your-- well,
you have to install
it into Apache.
But you put it in your
Apache configuration,
and then like this
service will automatically
optimize for bandwidth.
So, for instance,
in this case, it
will automatically
optimize for WebP images
if it knows that the
browser client can actually
handle them.
Sorry, I'm just
going to get a drink.
So performance is good,
and we like performance,
and we like having our
experiences work offline.
But the thing that
developers want
is they want their
experiences to work
kind of like they would expect
native applications to work.
They want to have access to all
the different types of device
functionality that
are available normally
for native applications.
Now, some of the stuff-- and the
biggest feature that developers
have asked for, I think,
about two years ago,
and we finally implemented it in
March, was push notifications.
If you're an Android
developer and you've
done kind of any GSN kind of
push-based notification before,
it's exactly the
same way of working.
The user has to opt in,
but once they've opted in,
your server can then
essentially send a notice
to the GCM service.
GCM will wake up the device,
and then inside the device
it will go, OK,
which ServiceWorker
needs to be woken up to actually
deliver this push notification?
And then the service
will wake up,
and then you will define exactly
how you want your experience
to kind of create a
push notification,
and these are native-like
push notifications as well.
You can have actions and a
whole bunch of other stuff,
and images are going
to come online soon.
But the whole point about
it is we're not actually
keeping the site open.
You can get these push
notifications even
when it's in the background.
And we're trying to save
as much battery as possible
because the
ServiceWorker will only
respond when GCM is
told it to wake up
and actually create
the notification.
So there is some kind
of interesting data
that we've got with this.
One of them is that we've
had a number of partners
and developers
implement this API.
Beyond the Rack is an
e-commerce company in America.
And when they implemented
push notifications,
they kind of did a trial
for about a month or two.
And one of the things
that they noticed
was that they saw a
72% increase in time
spent on site from users
responding and interacting
with the push notification.
And they saw a 26%
increase in average
spend of users who have
actually engaged, again,
via push notification.
So just with this one change,
they're not necessarily
progressive web apps,
but with this one change,
they've managed to meaningfully
impact their business
by actually be able
to provide this
without having to go through
kind of the costly app
install cycle.
And it's not just
Beyond the Rack
that are using it and Facebook.
We announced on
CO, I think, it's
a good couple
thousand developers
using push notifications.
And we're stand to see over
50 million messages a day
being sent through
the service, which
it's less than what you'd
expect from the Android
side of things.
But we've only just
got started with this,
and we're seeing great traction.
But it's not just
about an engagement,
and engagement isn't just
about using push notifications
and trying to get the
user to reuse your app.
It's about trying to interact
with all of the capabilities
inside the device.
So I kind of briefly want
to cover some of the things
that we can do.
I'm not going to go into
a huge amount detail.
But all with the
user's permission,
you can access the camera
and kind of be responsive.
You can take an image and
upload it and manipulate it.
You can understand kind
of what the user's saying,
but you can access their
microphone with, again,
with the user's
permission, and be
able to build
audio-based applications.
You can understand
the network stack,
whether the user's online,
whether they're using
Wi-Fi or a cellular connection.
We can also access
the user's location.
Again, it's been
there for years.
But we can access the
user's location, again,
entirely with their permission.
We don't get it straight away.
And one of the
interesting things
that's coming really
soon is the ability
to discover devices
that are around you that
are broadcasting via BLE,
connect to those devices,
and then interact with
any kind of BLE device,
just via JavaScript,
without having to have
a native application installed.
And finally, you can
integrate with things
like the native subsystems
via the Android intense system
and kind of integrate with
the Android native share
and API just via using
an intense syntax URL.
So the web platform
itself, especially
on Chrome for Android, is
actually quite powerful,
and it enables you to build
these rich experiences.
They can work offline.
They can work in kind of spotty
network connectivity issues.
The reason why I like
progressive web apps
as a concept is
because you don't
want to install
the experience, you
can still use that experience
and engage with the users.
But as the user
becomes more engaged
and they start using your
service more and more,
you can get it installed.
You can level it up,
use push notifications,
and all these things
as the user goes along.
It's a really
powerful way to think
about how you're building
the next generation of web
experiences.
I just want to leave
with one last thing,
and I've seen this a lot
in the general industry.
It's happened in India.
It's happened in the UK as well.
And there's massive focus on
developers going app only.
I think app only is the wrong
strategy for developers.
Again, think web only is
also the wrong strategy
for developers.
It's a much more nuanced
kind of landscape.
But fundamentally,
the web is critical
to your mobile strategy
and your mobile story
overall because the
power of the web
is the fact that you
can give someone a link.
They can click on it and start
using your experience straight
away.
And then you can level them up.
And then when you need to,
when the browser platform
can't take advantage
of some of the features
that have just come
to the web platform,
geofencing might be
one of the examples,
then you can
naturally upgrade them
into the native experience.
But the important
thing is there.
You've got the
user straightaway.
You've engaged with them.
They love your service.
They love your brand.
And they're much more likely to
actually keep engaging with it
and then install
your applications.
So with that, I just want
to say thank you very much,
and I've gone a
little bit over time.
But I'd like to introduce
Jason back to the stage.